scatterplots deal with something you see
before I just have a cold it
if you is bivariate Donna I want you to
have a guess as to what you think
by various means in engineering there
there's data which has two one two
variable kind of quantitative so have a
look at this one for instance
this is bivariate data there are two
parts to it have a look at the axis
piece this is weight versus height okay
so the way that you would say is is they
have plotted weight against hunt I'm
trying to compare does weight have
anything to do with height and the
answer is well of course it does but
they're loosely connected right just
because you're a certain weight that
doesn't automatically mean you're
certain height nor buys versa okay so
you can see that this is the scatterplot
why do they call it a scatter plot
because when you plot the points the
doctor scattered all around okay and you
can see here generally speaking before
you weigh the taller you are generally
speakers design make sense like your
very very few people who are very very
small but also really tall though for
what it's worth
do you see where you are you can leave
me Jenny well you're an actual bot I'm
here
I'm just looking for where I am yeah I'm
terrible ah yeah I am um I'm in fear
that's where I am so yeah this is this
is what we went to church anyway so yeah
yes those 14 but that was the very very
last exercise actually of chapter 14
mark well we didn't do the exercise
because 19 definitely the exercise
really interests me but it's different
how basically does way to myself that's
a boutique 2010 so now I should turn it
on and I'll let you have a look at these
so here's the scatter plots have a look
at each of these graphs a B and C and I
want you to think about what each one
tells you okay so the graph a do you see
how they're pretty much randomly spread
out do is that so what this means is
that for example if we went back to
waiting time right that means if you
were like this way you could be any
height at all there's people all of you
who are regular clients for the same way
or correspondingly if you go to a
particular height you can say I can find
anyone who's the same way and they're
also aired on is a different way and
they're all same time in which case that
means there's no actual relationship
here okay waiting high odds connected in
any way of course we know that's
actually not the case there is a
connection that looks more like this one
okay so this connection sorry I'm going
to be worth today between the two
variables is called correlation you see
it up there it's all available okay so
only for this I love you right
correlation is a measure of how closely
related this is by very dots so there
are two variables how close the other
two variables related
oh do you need a drink of these see if a
set of primary diet has high correlation
that means if you're one thing you're
going to be another like guaranteed I
have a great deal of certainty about it
okay
whereas if they have very low
correlation it's like even what you can
tell me this is innovation I have no
idea really about where what I'm going
to be in the other variable